hey how's it going bros my name is peter
pan today we're gonna do a video with
ace Lee over here are you sure about
this
okay I guess we'll make it with cutie
pie and cutie pie
have you ever wore one of these
okay well that now's the time so this
channel has just gone from complete
originality to complete originality
everyone has done this there's nothing
new that's it but let's do it I
understand anything you're saying okay
no whistle who can do that it okay
okay challenge Naruto
drew :
I thought it would work next challenge
rate our nose
that's time sick again
dude that's not
ow whoa how do you do it
that son is the best evil laugh you
could pull off okay I'm not even gonna
try this there's no it could be next
time okay hi that's challenge okay okay
I don't know what to call this but we
did it and it was fun leave your like if
you enjoyed
check out Maxie I don't check out Matt
see they were like be enjoyed and as
always
deserve it as where you get being me
person give us something stronger we
need that crunch come on